[Music]
at the very least turkey has become a
transit point for people traveling to
fight in syria
and for those trying to escape
through these streets we were taken to
meet a man who has fled syria
because of what he has seen and what he
has done
he calls himself saleh he is the only
person
who has ever seen jihadi john kill
and admit to seeing it his victim
japanese journalist kenji gotto
this man was there he saw it happen
the person that everyone is talking
about who's known as jihadi john
muhammad
firstly is that the man that we
see in the many videos is that him
and did you see him kill exactly
can you tell me uh
when he called kenji goto
i live should this
but not nearly from
a little a little but you saw him do
this
and it is definitely him i was shot
i was so would he have done
more of the killings
saleh paints a picture of a man who is
in charge
the masked man he calls john many call
mohammed emwazi
he is he says the chief killer of
foreigners
for islamic state's media arm and after
he kills what does he do to the body or
does he just leave
and after he was killed him
three or four persons coming to
the body button car
after that john went
diffic a different beat toward any road
is he in charge is he the boss
of the killing maybe
explain a little maybe the big
boss was there
with them
turkish man say
but oh this camera there change
blaze there but
john the weak boss all-time old time say
to all
fastly fastly fastly firstly
we should finish so he's pushing it
along
and when are people scared of him or do
they
do they they respect him
uh so respect him so
only he take only
others do so he gives the orders on
everything
and why is he so powerful
why is he the boss maybe because he
used lana as a knife
i don't i i cannot understand
why he is trying
but it could be because he does the
killing and is happy to do it
maybe one man can
kill old people
will respect can you explain how the
killing is done
foreigners are treated differently to
the locals
syria syrian man
anyone can kill him
but strangely and strange man
only john and it's always john
[Applause]
islamic state's ability to manipulate
social media to promote jihad with
professionally produced films as well
documented
although you are more than eight
thousand and five hundred kilometers
away from the islamic state
but it's the treatment and graphic
murder of their hostages
a translator but he was used to do a
different job
he was employed by a turkish man to
convince the hostages they were safe
every single one of the murdered was
subjected to mock executions
many many times until it became normal
then they met john he was saying to me
say to them no problem we
only with you we don't kill you
we want from we want from your
government
stop attack syria
we don't have any problem with you we
are
all you are only our
racists
so this they
don't worry any
uh always i
said to to them don't worry
doesn't matter nothing
nothing dangerous for you
but at the end you show
under i was sure what were they treating
them like
no uh maybe writes here
her voice but without hating
why all time he said to him it's a
brother
don't afraid don't afraid because we
he won't this my i will explain
he want when he will kill you really
don't enter his head
you exactly you
of course you should you say this
message
i'm living in isis uh it's
back here and you will stay will
continue salah says that the command and
control structure of
islamic state in iraq is dominated by
foreigners in fact
says that there are about 70 percent
foreign fighters against 30
syrians and there are more coming he was
used to facilitate the arrival of new
recruits
passing through predominantly arab towns
like this one
in turkey crucially though he was also
involved in the interrogation
of new hostages this man
from england
netherlands i don't know but he was a
hostage
and he was speaking english yes but in
with an
accent you didn't understand he was
speaking english
in so nice
sometimes i don't understand for him and
understand
what he said what did he look like
he was what musk he was most
all questions around the gun around
your job in syria who sent you to syria
who is your partner there
when will you come to syria where
you stayed in idlib
and alibaba all things
answer give answer
no i'm breeze i'm pleased
so after that he said to me
turkishman please don't worry
don't worry oh after that he was
so afraid he was very afraid
salah has left because of what he has
seen and he is scared
the guilt he feels compounded by his
ability to convince the hostages
they were amongst friends to calm him
kinjigoto was given an arab name
abusad is given the hostic
hostage idea if you will you should be
muslim
and come with us
when i was went to
to provo he said to go to
abu saad
maybe i i was strong in myself
maybe they try to this
old name is so hard any
kinji goto maybe he cannot say
abu said but when i not noticed it go to
when
they said abu said go to haman direct
uh relax
so you think he thought he was going to
be one of them
and you don't lose his life but they'd
all do
[Music]
almost all
[Music]
scared and emotional salah ended the
interview
he left knowing his life like those of
the hostages is now
in permanent danger from islamic state
stuart ramsey sky news turkey